[Music]
[Applause]
performed on russia's celebrity circuit
even playing the kremlin for a show seen
on the state-run channels
the latvian pop singer was a star in
russia
[Music]
for years he went on concert tours
across the vast country
singing in russian
he loved the culture and people
and celebrated them in his performances
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i still can't quite believe it's all
over
[Music]
i hope my russian fans don't take it
personally
but as long as putin's regime is in
power i'm not coming
in
concerts earned him plenty of money
even after russia's annexation of crimea
in violation of international law
this performance was on the biggest
network
channel 1 russia
[Applause]
lots of people are blaming me
i know i know i'm guilty
but i really loved it
i loved the big concert halls the big
audiences the millions of people the
support
but then came the war and a change of
heart for the 44 year old pop star
we talked with him in a studio
[Music]
is now recording a song for peace for
ukraine
[Music]
he's taking a stance at long last as
many here in latvia are saying
he started posting information and
videos about the war on his social media
channels
[Music]
he wants to confront his russian fans
with the reality of the invasion
to show the death and devastation which
they don't see on strictly state
controlled russian tv
[Music]
the images shocked as fans and many
reacted
[Music]
paradox
it's a huge paradox
the biggest fans who wrote the nicest
comments have turned into the biggest
enemies
they've gone crazy attacking me
it isn't without risk for vasulus we
filmed at his barn but he asked us not
to show where he lives because those who
consume russian state media live in
their own echo chamber
nearly a quarter of latvians are
ethnically russian
putin's propaganda has reached the
baltic republic driving a wedge through
the population
on may 9 the day marking victory over
nazi germany tens of thousands lay
flowers at soviet memorials in riga
many of them support the war of
aggression against ukraine which russian
propaganda has portrayed as a battle
against nazism
basulus has experienced the consequences
of this propaganda personally on the
streets of his own hometown he's taken
abuse from people accusing him of
spreading lies about russia
[Music]
they cursed me
but i say to them
friend
it's all fine i understand you.
don't worry it's not your fault for
thinking that
yeah
you're a victim of propaganda
though
[Applause]
wants to change his fans perspective
he hopes they'll open their eyes to what
is happening
after the war he'd like to take his
children along to one of his concerts in
russia
but only if it's a different russia
without putin
you